PANDEMIC KILLED PEOPLE FROM OF
ALL AGES FROM EVERY WALK OF
LIFE.
>> Reporter: FEW OF US IMAGINED
THE OVERWHELMING SCOPE OF THIS
TRAGEDY.
MORE THAN 1 MILLION LIVES LOST.
FAR SURPASSING THE FLU PANDEMIC
OR THE CIVIL WAR.
ACROSS THE NATION, THE TIME OF
REMEMBRANCE.
IN LOS ANGELES, MARIA ZANTOS
PETERSON DEVOTED HER LIFE TO
CARING FOR OTHERS AS AN ICU
NURSE AT THE VA HOSPITAL.
LAST YEAR SHE TRAVELLED TO
CENTRAL AMERICA ON HER LAST
MEDICAL MISSION.
SHE LEAVES BEHIND HER HUSBAND,
AND TEENAGE SON.
IN VIRGINIA, THERESA SPERRY'S
PARENTS REMEMBER THEIR DAUGHTER,
ALWAYS OPEN TO TAKING CARE OF
OTHERS.
AT HILL POINT ELEMENTARY, THE
10-YEAR-OLD WAS KNOWN TO BANDAGE
HER CLASSMATES.
SIMILAR HEARTACHES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, IN COMMUNITIES OF ALL
CREED AND COLOR.
IN NEW YORK, A HISPANIC
COMMUNITY HIT HARD, TO
CONGREGATIONS UNITED IN GRIEF
AFTER LOSING MORE THAN 100
MEMBERS.
>> Translator: THERE ARE MOMENTS
WE CAN'T EXPLAIN WITH REASON.
WE HAVE TO WALK IN FAITH, FEEL
OUR OWN VULNERABILITY, TO CARE
FOR OURSELVES AND CARE FOR
OTHERS.
>> Reporter: IN THE BORDER
COUNTY OF HIDALGO, TEXAS, MORE
THAN 3500 DEATHS IN THE COUNTY
OF LESS THAN A MILLION.
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT EVERYONE
HAS SLOWED DOWN ENOUGH TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHO IS MISSING AND
WHAT'S MISSING.
WHAT GAPS THEY HAVE LEFT.
>> Reporter: GAPS THAT MAY NEVER
FULLY HEAL.
IN MARYLAND, THE FIRST BLACK
U.S. SECRETARY OF STATE, GENERAL
COLIN POWELL, PASSED AWAY.
POWELL'S LEADERSHIP IN SEVERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS HELPED SHAPE
AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY AT THE
TURN OF THE CENTURY.
>> WE UNDERSTOOD THAT EVEN AMONG
ALLIES DISAGREEMENTS ARISE AND
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS TO COME BACK
TOGETHER.
>> Reporter: IN NASHVILLE, THE
MUSIC WORLD LOST PROLIFIC
SESSION DRUMMER KENNY MALONE.
♪ JOLENE ♪
>> Reporter: THE PERCUSSION
PROVIDED THE BACKBONE FOR DOLLY
PARTON'S NUMBER ONE HIT
"JOLENE."
ALSO GONE, LEGENDARY DEEJAY PAUL
JOHNSON.
THE KEY FIGURE IN THE CHICAGO
HOUSE MUSIC SCENE OF THE '90s.
JOHNSON'S SINGLE "GET GET DOWN"
WAS A GLOBAL SENSATION.
♪♪
>> Reporter: IN NEW HAMPSHIRE,
WILLIAM AND CAROL STEWART DIED
HOLDING HANDS.
MARRIED FOR 44 YEARS, THEY HAD
KNOWN EACH OTHER SINCE THEY WERE
JUST 4 YEARS OLD.
DAUGHTER MELISSA BELIEVES HER
PARENTS WERE SOUL MATES.
>> I LOVE YOU.
AND I WILL SEE YOU AGAIN SOME
DAY.
>> Reporter: IN UKIPA,
CALIFORNIA, A MOTHER AND FATHER
LEAVE BEHIND FIVE CHILDREN.
DANNY DIED A WEEK AFTER GIVING
BIRTH TO HER FIFTH CHILD.
HER HUSBAND DIED A WEEK LATER.
THE CHILDREN NOW LIVE WITH
GRANDPARENTS.
IN BELGRADE, FLORIDA, A FAMILY
TORN APART.
LISA WILSON HAD GONE DOOR TO
DOOR TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
VACCINATED AS PART OF HER WORK
FOR THE COUNTY.
DESPITE HER BEST EFFORTS TO SAVE
LIVES, SHE LOST SIX RELATIVES IN
THE SPAN OF THREE WEEKS.
BURYING HER OWN 89-YEAR-OLD
GRANDMOTHER AND UNCLE AND FOUR
COUSINS.
IN COMMUNITIES EVERYWHERE,
FAMILIES, FRIENDS AND LOVED ONES
FIND SYMBOLS OF REMEMBRANCE WITH
FLAGS AT THE NATIONAL MALL.
THE BURNING CANDLE AT CHICAGO'S
NAVY PIER.
MONARCH BUTTERFIES IN EL PASO.
IN BELL MAR, NEW JERSEY, A
MAKESHIFT BEACH MEMORIAL.
RIMA WROTE HER BROTHER'S NAME ON
A SINGLE STONE.
SOON THERE WERE 3,000 MORE.
AND IN LOS ANGELES, A TEEN
COMMEMORATES HER CITY'S FALLEN
THROUGH A PATCHWORK QUILT, THAT
IS NOW A GLOBAL PROJECT OF
HEALING.
>> BEHIND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE SQUARES IS A PERSON.
AND NOT JUST A PERSON WHO DIED,
BUT A PERSON WHO LIVED.
THEY STILL ARE IN PEOPLE'S
HEARTS AND MEMORIES.
>> Reporter: ONE OF THE QUILT
SQUARES OFFERS A SIMPLE MESSAGE
OF H